welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka hank jim spiration in
this video we're breaking down episode 3
of marvel's what if the entry massively
changes up the mcu and features the
death of some of our favorite phase one
characters before they could go on to
become legends it's got a big twist and
after the last three episodes ended with
cliffhangers it does seem like this
season might end up being all connected
now in this video we're going to be
breaking down the easter eggs hidden
details things you missed yes you and
also giving our thoughts on what could
be happening in the series now the
episode takes place across the week that
iron man 2 thor and the incredible hulk
happened this was a very pivotal moment
in the timeline as it was the point in
which several events all happened and
it's arguably the most important week in
the mcu we start off with the title
screen which we broke down in our
episode 1 video in case you want to
check it out this episode probably has
the biggest names that have featured in
the series so far and we get vocal
performances from samuel l jackson
jeremy renner mark ruffalo tom
hiddleston clark gregg frank grillo and
jamie alexander interestingly in the
incredible hulk bruce banner was of
course played by edward norton and this
what if scenario recasts him as the mcu
mainstay mark ruffalo to kind of keep
him more in line with the continuity the
episode kick starts with a big title
screen that says monday implementing
this idea of a week and it runs all the
way up to friday the episode culminates
with us getting what could be a weekend
game hey as different heroes are brought
together to form an alternate version of
the avengers now it is possible that
this title screen is referencing the
movie 7 starring brad pitt and morgan
freeman as that took place over the
space of a week and had title cards
denoting each day nick fury starts off
his infamous avengers speech by saying
there was an idea
this featured in the avengers film and
it was later repurposed for the infinity
war trailer it was actually used in the
description of that trailer and it
starts off one of the most infamous
speeches in the mcu however it's cut
short by black widow who has clearly
heard it several times before we are
currently set in the time period of iron
man 2 and we see tony sitting inside a
giant donut mirroring the moment from
that movie in which the same thing
happened stark is currently suffering
from palladium poisoning due to the arc
reactor being toxic it's also possible
that he was overloaded with it at the
end of the first iron man movie as when
peppa set the reactor to blow she pushed
a button that released a lot of
palladium gas this is in the aftermath
of his fight with roadie and though the
lines that nick says to him are
identical to what he says in iron man 2
we get to see things just before this
scene from another perspective nat has
her hang-ups over recruiting stark to
save the world but fury reminds her that
he also recruited a russian spy
and that the team is pretty much going
to be made up of misfits i was actually
kind of hoping rodney would show up at
the end of the movie to be part of the
new avengers as at this point in iron
man 2 he does have the war machine armor
now moving on from that the anime has
perfectly recaptured the feeling and
look of this scene from the movie
everything in the diner even down to the
veins in stock's neck looks identical
and it does a great job of reminding us
how much attention to detail that marvel
are paying stock lowers his glasses much
in the same way that howard did in the
first avenger and black widow approaches
him believing that she's applying a cure
into his neck playing these moments on
top of one another you can see how well
they line up but a big change comes when
we realize that tony has been injected
with a little dose that has killed him
the watch narrates the concept of the
entry and we see several shots from iron
man 2 including the mirror one and when
the character fought whiplash the
watcher described stalk as being a
genius who battled his demons both
inside and out and this is referencing
the fact that iron man 2 gave some notes
to the seminal tony stark comic demon in
a bottle he's a demon in a bottle got a
rope in there
now he describes the hulk as being a
monster hiding in a man and also refers
to thor as a godly prince who fell to
earth we also get some shots of the
avengers film namely the chittari
attacking hawkeye and black widow as
well as hulk going smash on loki like
how he did in stock tower we get the
avengers money shot and this is actually
been referenced in the what if trailer
but rather than having the classic
avengers we get what i believe is
killmonger thanos gamora t'challa
starlord and party thor this makes me
believe that we'll be getting a
multiversal team up at the end of the
season but i'll talk about that later on
in the video cut to a scene that
appeared both in thor and in the
post-credits scene of iron man 2. we
start with a close-up of the hammer
before joining agent coulson who has
arrived at the scene to alert fury that
it's been found black widow is now being
blamed for the murder of tony and she's
being escorted by crossbones and jack
rollins two characters that were big
parts of captain america the winter
soldier crossbones mentions pierce aka
alexander pierce who at this time was of
course the head of shield he was also a
hydra agent and though he doesn't show
up in this entry i love how the episode
keeps throwing things to us like this
whilst we try to get to the bottom of
who's killing the avengers fury knows it
wasn't widow but due to her being an
ex-russian agent shield of course
suspects her he tasks her with getting
to the bottom of it and she's escorted
by the hydra agents in a scene that sort
of feels reminiscent to the elevator one
in the winter soldier might be a bit of
a reach but both are in small metal
containers and completely kicking the
crap out of everyone else now due to the
changes in the timeline nick fury is now
attending the mullier crash site
alongside hawkeye we last saw the pair
together at the end of the captain
carter episode and because of the
post-credits scene of thor we know that
in the main timeline that he was at
project pegasus at this point rather
than in the desert because coulson isn't
the one overseeing the operation he
works the perimeter and discovers that
thor has been smashing people's heads in
like you should smash that like button
also yeah whilst you're here don't
forget to subscribe as we're doing big
breakdowns on the show every week and
i'll also give you a tenner when i
become a billionaire that's a bloody
promise soon as i'm a billionaire you
are rich as well now i love the way that
coulson sort of gets fanny flutters over
thor and also his hair often in the mcu
people have said that he's a bloody
handsome bloke and infinity war we of
course saw as the guardian stood around
him saying that he looked like an angel
this happened whilst delay on a slab and
it's sort of mirrored in this episode in
the following scene when colton and fury
stand around sniffing him bit weird now
hawkeye goes to the bird's nest and
starts to stalk him with a bow and arrow
however something makes him release the
arrow and thor is killed this might
actually be a nod to civil war 2 and in
that comic book storyline hawkeye
actually killed the hulk and got put on
trial because of it now because of this
we learn that loki gets control of the
throne and in thor's solo movie he of
course stopped this before it could
happen hawkeye is killed and initially
carlson suspects that he took a cyanide
capsule however fury brings up his wife
and kids who were of course introduced
in age of ultron hawkeye downplayed
having them and even said that he didn't
have a girlfriend earlier in the film
but we discovered the truth later on
fury was actually one of the only people
that knew and that's why he went to
clint's home at one point in the film
and broke bread with the family guy
broke bread and [ __ ] now coulson asks if
nick has any idea who's behind it all
and he hilariously says there was an
idea which yeah nice bit of dialogue cut
to wednesday and the culver university
in virginia this is a location that we
were introduced to in the incredible
hulk and we learned that it's where
bruce carried out the majority of his
experiments the university has several
cameos there including one by lou
ferrigno who of course played the jolly
green giant in the 70s tv show we also
caught a young scientist who you might
recognize as being the person who would
go on to become peter's science teacher
in spider-man homecoming in addition to
this it also appeared in agents of
shield showing that it's all connected
now we catch betty ross carrying some
books and the colors of these are purple
and green which are of course the color
schemes that the incredible hulk uses
one is for microbiology and both she and
bruce were of course studying ways to
unlock untapped potential within the
human body that would basically
replicate the super soldier serum they
do a bit of retconning here to show that
widow and ross have met before but i
can't remember them meeting in the mcu
which is either because it didn't happen
or it's because i sat up all night
downing 19 cans of red bull so i could
get this video out 15 minutes after the
episode airs together the pair look over
the syringe and we learned that a tiny
projectile perhaps based on nanotech is
what killed stock this is one of the
major clues that it was actually hank
pym behind it which the episode
eventually reveals widow notices the
stanley pizza parlor uniform and this is
of course what bruce used to sneak into
the university with i always thought
that with the restaurant being called
stan lee's and also the fact that it was
an old guy running it that it would have
been the perfect cameo for stan lee but
for whatever reason they decided to get
another old white head dude instead no
idea why but i'm sure someone out there
knows so leave it in the comments below
now fury rings here and tells her that
hawkeye is dead and the former has
realized that all of the people being
murdered are connected to the avengers
initiative also yet whilst we're
nitpicking the mcu back when endgame
came out yet i called hawkeye mo hawkeye
because of his haircut it never caught
on and i've been furious about it since
then now she finds bruce i'm still angry
still angry no no she finds bruce hiding
behind a big green door and this could
be a note of the incredible hulk comic
namely immortal hulk in which the
passage between hell and the normal
world was accessible to the hulk through
a literal green door could be a reach
but bruce steps out and says that
violence probably isn't going to work
out for anyone and this is a nod to when
he and not met in the avengers nat
pretended to go to him by herself and he
warned her that if she tried to take him
in forcibly that it probably wouldn't
work out for her i actually love seeing
ruffalo in this role and it's nice that
both betty and widow are both in the
scene as they were of course love
interests for the character
interestingly veronica the satellite
that held the hulkbuster was named as a
nod to betty and veronica from archie
comics also huge apologies to my editor
christian at beyond epic for having to
edit me going off into these constant
easter egg side tangents i'm sorry bro
now in the desert we see loki coming
down through the bifrost this is
actually right near where thor landed in
the opening of the 2011 movie he has
brought within the asgardian army and
amongst them we can see the destroyer
which of course wasn't destroyed by thor
like it was in his solo film the
warriors three and ladies suffer
alongside loki and they didn't go to
earth because of the events changing
loki introduces himself as the crown
prince of asgard which was the position
that belonged to thor loki seeks
vengeance for his brother's death and he
ends up unleashing the casket of ancient
winters from thor i remember back in the
day there was a lot of confusion over
whether this was the tesseract or not
and seeing it unleashed here brought
back memories of arguing with people on
the internet over why it was a different
thing
ah my childhood now we see that nat is
ringing fury and curtain escorting bruce
across the bridge which was a big set
piece in the incredible hulk general
ross arrives but strangely emil blonsky
isn't with him who was of course the
abomination bruce is put in the
crosshairs and you might notice that
he's also wearing a denim blue shirt
over a white tee which is what the
character had on in his solo film the
hulk explodes internally and i guess
that answers the age-old question of
what would happen if ant-man shot up
thanos butthole fury offers loki a
compromise and says that they should
work together to find his brother's
killer loki gives him until the sun
rises in mid guard to track this person
down and it just puts a deadline on the
final act across the state we see now
attempting to get to the bottom of it by
accessing coulson's files and he gives
her his password which is hashtag steve
steve steve
ihotsteve0704 now not only is this
because we found out in the avengers
that coulson loves captain america
but the numbers themselves also hold the
special meaning in the first avenger on
cap's enlistment form we discovered that
his birthday was actually the fourth of
july so the zero seven zero four is
colton putting in the american way to
write someone's date of birth at the end
nat can't shake the feeling that she's
being watched and we do get some
foreshadowing here that hank is involved
when she pulls up the names of those
involved in the admin folder amongst
them we can see coulson fury maria hill
alexander pierce and janet van dyne aka
hank's wife who is thought to be
deceased x marks the spot as always and
the big line through her profile pic
hints towards us that everything is
connected to her in some way i'm not
gonna say it's all connected now she
turns out yeah she accessed the database
the day before even though she was dead
and although she is still alive and
widow is killed by hank as he
mercilessly beats the crap out of her
now not to make light on men hitting
women which is obviously something that
dude shouldn't do but we have seen this
characteristic from hank before one of
the most controversial moments in comic
book history happened when he was in the
yellowjacket costume and he beat his
wife it was later explained away as
being the pym particles that changed his
personality and this idea could also
lend itself to the reveal in the final
act in her dying words she screams out
that it's all about hope aka hank's
daughter and we cut to fury in a diner
without her and stalk which mirrors the
beginning of the episode and shows how
much he's lost colson reminds him that
the avengers were put in place to fight
tourettes like loki and they would of
course go against him in their first
team-up movie yuri returns to his car
and from the glove box he takes out
captain marvel's beeper which he of
course had during the post-credits scene
of infinity war rather than pulling it
out of that in a glove box though he had
it in a big bag and i love how there's
this idea that he always has it with him
just in case something big kicks off he
goes to loki who has transformed the
desert into a jotunheim-like area
completely frozen in ice this is because
loki is of course a frost giant and thus
it would feel more like home to him loki
disguised as fury visits hub's grave and
this is where he's approached by hank
voiced by michael douglas it's revealed
that hope died during a mission in the
odessa ukraine and this could be
something that we have heard about in
the mcu we discovered that when nat
escorted an engineer out of iran that
she was attacked by the winter soldier
he forced their vehicle off a cliff and
though nat managed to climb out with the
engineer bucky shot nat through the
stomach and killed him now it is
possible that with hank becoming the
yellow jacket in this timeline that his
daughter had an even more estranged
relationship with him and that she
joined shield and went out on this
mission perhaps the winter soldier
murdered her and thus hank lay the blame
at shield's feet going interval reach
richard's persona if the winter soldier
did kill hope then he would fully blame
shield because bucky was of course a
hydra agent working for them now we see
hank carrying out the murders and i'll
be honest i've watched this episode a
couple of times and the twist it doesn't
really work for me i don't know why hank
would care about murdering the avengers
that had nothing to do with his daughter
and personally i think that he would
just go after fury rather than killing
people that he might have recruited
let's be honest at this point they
weren't even the avengers so it's a bit
weird to me that hank would care about
people completely disconnected from the
organization that fury was thinking
about getting on board with the pair
then took it out and it's revealed that
fury is actually loki the latter
replicates himself and stands around
hank laughing which the character also
did at the end of thor now they managed
to stop hank but in doing this it ushers
in something far worse think of killing
he who remains and getting kang instead
and you get the idea loki refuses to
leave earth and decides to rule over mid
god which he of course wanted to do in
the avengers he attends the united
nations and speaks out over the world to
say that he will now be taking over
everything he says that humans crave
subjugation a direct quote from the
avengers when he was talking about how
we were made to be ruled we watches the
avengers coffins line a hangar and fury
steps forward with his next steps in the
plan he visits the captain america crash
site and wipes away the snow from the
front of the shield which is of course
pulling directly from the imagery of the
first avenger he says welcome back
captain and turns around to see that
captain marvel has arrived much in the
same way that she showed up in the
post-credits scene of her solo movie
rather than saying where's fury though
she now says where's the fight and we
end with the fate of the world up in the
air now every episode so far has ended
with a cliffhanger and it could be
teasing what's to come in the trailer
for what if we have seen several of the
characters join together in one timeline
and we know from the teaser that at some
point doctor strange meets with captain
carter i believe that he will be getting
characters from different universes and
possibly pulling them all together into
one timeline to save it the constant
cliffhangers definitely hint towards
that and who knows we might see captain
marvel and america from this earth
popping up further down the line
now as for this episode i think it was
pretty good on the whole i was just a
bit unsure on the twist and out of the
three it's probably my least favorite
though this time period is one of the
most important ones in the mcu it's also
a time period that i don't really write
that highly and iron man 2 the
incredible hulk and thor are probably
the bottom of my list when it comes to
ranking the films
yes i prefer dark world over thor 1. i
think this kind of didn't really get
going to the extent i was hoping and
though the mystery was good i just
thought the payoff was a bit meh when
tony died my first thought was that it
would be ant-man related so i didn't
really see it as being that big of a
twist and when black widow came across
janet i knew exactly what was going on
because i'm a god damn genius no yeah it
was pretty obvious wasn't it all that
being said though it's still a pretty
fun episode just probably the weakest
out of the three for me i think ranking
them so far i'd go to charlotte captain
carter then this the i'm sure people
have their differing opinions now i was
lucky enough to get early access to the
first three but from this point onwards
i'm going in as blind as you are because
of this the videos might come a bit
later next week but rest assured i'll
get them out on wednesday at some point
before then though i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the episode so make sure you
comment below and let me know we're
running a competition right now and
giving away three mcu box sets on the
30th of august and all you have to do to
be on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
you pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one on screen right now so message
me at heavy spoilers if that's you if
you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
this spider-man no way home trailer i'm
actually recording this the last
wednesday and i'm hoping that it's been
released if it's not though yeah i'm
sorry for letting you down i've got
another marvel video on screen right now
that is just as good i promise you might
not be the trailer or it might
and let's just see without the way thank
you for sticking through the video i've
been paul i'll see you next time take
care peace